Gabrielle SIERRA: Does the U.S.
consider Taiwan a country?
David SACKS: No.
SIERRA: Okay. But it's
possible that we may go to war
with our most powerful adversary
to defend its independence.
SACKS: To defend the status quo
and its de facto independence. Yes.
CBN News: Let’s begin this half hour in Asia where
Taiwan is getting ready for war with China.
CBN News: A popular saying among people here
is Ukraine today, Taiwan tomorrow.
ABC News: President Biden, last fall, saying
for the first time that if China invades Taiwan
the U.S. would send troops to defend it.
Xi Jinping: [Speaking in Mandarin]
SIERRA:
Tensions between China and Taiwan are one of the
world’s major fault lines. And in recent years,
those tensions have been ratcheting up.
SIERRA: China feels that Taiwan is part of
its territory, and has vowed to one day
reclaim it, and the history underneath that
claim is complex and tense. To make matters more
confusing, the U.S. stance on Taiwan has been kept
purposefully vague for decades - a policy that
has come to be known as strategic ambiguity.
SIERRA: Mixed up in all of this are the Taiwanese
people themselves, who of course have their own
nuanced perspectives on the situation.
SIERRA: My name is Gabrielle Sierra and this
is Why It Matters. Today a crash course on Taiwan,
and a glimpse into what a Chinese invasion could
mean for the world.
SACKS:
A Chinese invasion of Taiwan would likely be the
most complex modern military operation, something
that makes D-Day look small by comparison.
SIERRA: This is David Sacks - you actually heard
him at the top of the episode. He’s a fellow here
at the Council focusing on Taiwan and China. He’s
the director of the Council’s new Independent
Task Force report on Taiwan, which formed the
basis for this episode. You should totally
go check it out in the show notes page.
SACKS: We're talking about tens of thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands of Chinese soldiers
transiting the Taiwan Strait, Taiwan responding
by using force of its own. And we're likely
talking about large-scale casualties on both
sides. If the United States were to intervene
on Taiwan's behalf, I think there should be
no doubt that we're talking about casualties
on the U.S. side that make Iraq and Afghanistan
look small by comparison. And there's of course,
the large unknown, which is what happens when two
nuclear armed powers face off directly against
one another. Something that hasn't occurred
yet in history. China's military has advanced
capabilities from anti-ship ballistic missiles
to hypersonics and advanced fighter jets, all of
which would make U.S. defense of Taiwan incredibly
difficult. When people think about this conflict,
people often say that there's the potential that
you would see U.S. aircraft carriers at the bottom
of the ocean with thousands of casualties
as a result just of that alone. Of course,
it's hard to know for sure whether China could
put its capabilities to use and make that happen,
but we know for a fact that China is attempting
to do just that - hold major U.S. assets,
including aircraft carriers at risk.
SIERRA: War between the United States and
China. It’s not inevitable, but it is
possible. And even without military
conflict between the U.S. and China, an
invasion of Taiwan has the power to stop
the global economy in its tracks.
SACKS: A Chinese blockade or invasion,
the moment it starts, the world's busiest
shipping lanes grind to a halt. We would be
talking about a global economic depression that
would not only shave trillions of dollars off
global GDP in the first year, but I would argue
it would be incredibly difficult to recover and
reverse the economic impact. The other thing that
I would say is the impact that this would have on
international order. We've seen one authoritarian
country attack a democratic neighbor and attempt
to grab territory. If China did the same to
Taiwan, this would set a pattern of authoritarian
countries doing so. We look at Taiwan as a vibrant
democracy in a region of the world where there
aren't many democracies. By some measures, Taiwan
is the freest society in Asia, and a Chinese
assault on Taiwan and annexation of Taiwan would
extinguish a democracy of twenty-three million.
And I think that would have pretty chilling
effects for other young democracies around the
world. Of course, there would be massive human
costs for the twenty-three million people of
Taiwan as well that we should keep in mind. And
so I think some might say, "Well, this is not
my problem," but I think that this is all of our
problems. You should have no doubt that this would
have profound implications for your life.
SIERRA: I think that a lot of Americans have,
of course, heard of Taiwan but don't necessarily
know much beyond the headlines. So I was wondering
if you could humor me with some basics.
James LIN: Sure. So Taiwan is an island off
the southeastern coast of China, about
a hundred miles away. It's not a small
island. It's not a large island. I believe it's
around the size of the state of Maryland.
SIERRA: This is James Lin. He’s an assistant
professor of international studies and history
at the University of Washington where
he teaches and researches Taiwan.
LIN: So Taiwan is in a multi-party democracy. Many
of the kinds of democratic indexes like V-Dem,
which is one that many political scientists
rely on, rates Taiwan as a highly free,
highly democratic society.
SIERRA: Is Taiwan its own country,
or is it part of China?
SACKS: Well, that depends on who you ask. Only
around a dozen countries in the world recognize
Taiwan as a sovereign independent country and the
United States is not one of those countries.
The United States does not recognize it as a
sovereign independent country. But if you walk
down the streets of Taipei or anywhere in Taiwan,
it looks and acts like a country. It has its own
military, its own currency and elected government.
And of course, to the Taiwanese people who live on
the island, Taiwan is very much its own country.
To the People's Republic of China, Taiwan is
essentially a renegade province, something that
must be restored to the PRC by force if necessary.
So for the United States, our position is a little
difficult to understand, but it is that Taiwan's
status is undetermined. So we haven't reached the
endpoint yet at which point you could determine
whether Taiwan is a part of China, an independent
entity, or something else.
SIERRA: The stakes are high,
and China’s sensitivity to the issue is so
strong, that diplomats the world over walk
on eggshells when discussing Taiwan.
SIERRA: In fact, we don’t usually do this
but check out this moment from a recent
CFR event in which Secretary of State
Antony Blinken tactfully reinforces the
United States’ ambiguous stance to our
president emeritus Richard Haass:
Richard HAASS: So four times your boss,
the President of the United States, has said
that the U.S. would help defend Taiwan if it
were attacked by China. And four times the White
House staff has walked him back. So what is our
policy? And Why aren’t we basically telling China,
within the context of a One China policy, you’ve
done things to increase the threat, we’re going to
do things to increase your understanding that you
cannot move against Taiwan with impunity?
Antony BLINKEN: Richard...
HAASS: Yes, sir?
BLINKEN: We
continue to be guided by the One China
policy based on the Three Communiques,
the Taiwan Relations Act, and the Six Assurances.
That hasn’t changed and that won’t change.
SACKS: The Biden administration has been quite
consistent that it still maintains the U.S. One
China policy. But at the same time, there have
been questions about whether strategic ambiguity
remains U.S. policy, which is different than
the One China policy. President Biden on four
occasions has seemed to endorse what we would
call strategic clarity, saying that if China
attacked Taiwan, he would respond and defend
Taiwan. Even though the administration walked
it back on each occasion, to me, it's important
that we take note of that. So my own view is that
we shouldn't view President Biden's statements
as gaffes. I think that he fully understands the
implications of what he says. This is a man who
has an experienced foreign policy track record,
was on the Senate Foreign Relations Committee. In
fact, when George W. Bush said a similar thing as
president, then Senator Joe Biden wrote an op-ed
in the Washington Post criticizing him for his
lack of discipline on this question. So in my
view, President Biden has been very clear and
has said on four times that if he were faced with
this monumental decision as commander-in-chief of
whether to come to Taiwan's defense, he would
do so. And I think that it's important that we
take him at his word, and I think that the Chinese
also take him at his word, and they believe that
he was serious with what he said.
SIERRA: How have other countries
treated this situation?
LIN: So today, most countries
deal with Taiwan on an unofficial basis. There
are a small number of nations - a little bit
over a dozen - who still continue to maintain
diplomatic relations with Taiwan only. Usually,
these are small South Pacific or Latin American
nations. And Beijing has sometimes tried to
convince them to switch recognition in different
ways. So very recently, there's been some changes
around that. But for the most part, Taiwan is not
recognized as a country, and so has to conduct
relations in this kind of informal fashion.
SIERRA: Okay, so it’s not just the U.S. Most of
the world is in the same touchy dilemma.
They can’t afford to acknowledge Taiwan as
a country openly - the cost would be far too
high in terms of China’s reaction. And yet,
at the same time, many countries engage in
warm, if careful, relations with Taiwan.
SIERRA: To understand this strange balance,
and the potential for war if it fails, we have
to turn to history. How did we get here?
SIERRA: First thing’s first, indigenous people
have resided in Taiwan for thousands of years. And
they are still an important part of the island’s
culture. But, through the centuries, Taiwan was
repeatedly colonized, by the Chinese, the Dutch,
and most recently by Japan in 1895. But the
trends that explain the current situation
really begin after World War II, when China was
consumed by a bloody civil war that ultimately
led to the ascension of the Chinese Communist
Party that governs the country today.
Real Time History: The Qing Dynasty had ruled
China for nearly four hundred years, but the old
ways were coming to an end. Republicanism,
war-lordism, nationalism, and communism
struggled for supremacy through revolution and
a twenty-two year civil war between an ambitious
generalissimo and a guerilla revolutionary.
SACKS: After World War II, the Chinese Civil War
really takes shape, pitting Mao's Communists
against Chiang Kai-shek and the Nationalists.
The United States sides with Chiang Kai-shek and
the Nationalists because they were allies during
World War II. But for a number of reasons, the
Nationalists lose out to the Communists in the
Civil War, and Chiang Kai-shek and the KMT
and his followers retreat to Taiwan in 1949,
as Mao declares the establishment of the
People's Republic of China that same year.
Mao Zedong: [Speaking in Mandarin]
SACKS: Now, at that point, the United
States was frustrated with Chiang Kai-shek,
a sense that he didn't take our advice,
that we had given enough aid and support,
but essentially, he lost the civil war,
and we wanted to cut our losses there.
So the Truman administration essentially
resigns itself to Mao at some point, taking over
Taiwan and absorbing that into the PRC. But then
the next major event that happens that changes
the course of history really is the Korean War,
which erupts in the summer of 1950.
British Movietone: The peoples of the free
world, acting under the United Nations, have
given their answer, and the United States,
in a swift, bold decision has already gone
into action. Air power first and sea power
with the Seventh Fleet ordered to protect Formosa
together with reinforcements for the Philippines
and more aid to French Indo-China.
SACKS: President Truman sends the U.S. Navy into
the Taiwan Strait to prevent Mao from using this
as an opportunity to take over Taiwan. As the Cold
War had solidified, the United States didn't want
to see the communist North Korea attacking South
Korea and Mao's communist forces attacking Taiwan
and wanted to lock in the separation, at least
for the time being. And the Truman Administration
changes the U.S. position on Taiwan, that Taiwan's
status remained undetermined and had to await the
restoration of peace in the Asia-Pacific.
Harry S. Truman: When Japan returns to its place
in the family of nations and with the people
of Korea secure, free, and united, it should be
possible to find ways to settle other problems in
the Pacific which now threaten the peace.
LIN: Over time, people began to realize that
Beijing's government, the People's Republic of
China, was going to stay, and many countries began
to switch recognition. I would say the turning
point was in 1971, when the United Nations General
Assembly voted to replace the representative
of China with the People’s Republic of China,
the government based in Beijing. And that was a
turning point where many people or many countries
thought to themselves, "The United Nations has
replaced the official representation. We should
probably switch recognition as well." Under
the Nixon administration, Henry Kissinger,
who was the national security advisor secretly
went to Beijing to negotiate with Zhou Enlai,
who was the foreign minister at the time, to
negotiate a rapprochement basically. So this
was during the Cold War, when the United States
was in this kind of high level conflict with the
Soviet Union. And Nixon and Kissinger came up with
a strategy to isolate the Soviet Union by picking
off one of their allies. And so in exchange for
the United States kind of re-engaging the PRC,
Zhou Enlai asked Kissinger to take a position
on Taiwan. And so this eventually came out to
be what's called the One China policy.
Richard Nixon: I want to put our policy in
the clearest possible context. Our
action in seeking a new relationship
with the People’s Republic of China will
not be at the expense of our old friends.
I have taken this action because of my
profound conviction that all nations
will gain from a reduction of tensions and
a better relationship between the United
States and the People’s Republic of China.
SACKS: So, what that means is essentially the
United States recognizes the People's Republic
of China as the sole legal government of China,
and it acknowledges the Chinese position that
Taiwan is a part of China. But importantly,
it does not endorse or recognize China's view
that Taiwan is a part of China. So the One
China policy has a lot of ambiguity built into
it, and the U.S. relationship with Taiwan has
evolved over time. But the core tenets of the One
China policy, which is really about diplomatic
relations with Taiwan, remain in place.
Jimmy Carter: The government of the United
States of America acknowledges the Chinese
position that there is but one China.
Bill Clinton: I believe that both
China and Taiwan want to stay on
the path to prosperity and dialogue.
George W. Bush: The issue that really is the
issue of the future, in many ways, is China.
Barack Obama: There’s probably no bilateral
relationship that carries more significance.
Donald Trump: I don’t know why we have
to be bound by a One China policy.
Joe Biden: We agree with a One China policy,
but the idea that it can be taken by
force is just not appropriate.
SIERRA: The One China policy has remained
in place, and helped keep the peace,
under every president since Richard Nixon.
SIERRA: However the executive branch was not the
only part of government that was interested
in the China-Taiwan relationship. In 1979,
Congress passed the Taiwan Relations Act, or TRA,
which created the American Institute in Taiwan,
a nonprofit organization that oversees America's
unofficial relationship with Taiwan. Many see it
as a kind of unofficial embassy.
SIERRA: The TRA holds that the United
States would view "any effort to determine
the future of Taiwan by other than peaceful
means...a threat to the peace and security of
the Western Pacific area and of grave concern."
It also pledges that the United States will
provide Taiwan with defensive arms. While the
TRA does not obligate the United States to
defend Taiwan, it does state that the United
States will maintain the capacity to do so.
SIERRA: The right to defend Taiwan, but not the
obligation. A nonprofit organization but not an
embassy. It’s a careful dance, and as a result,
visits between American and Taiwanese leaders
are rare. When they do happen, they tend to
make headlines. You may recall that last year
former Speaker of the House, Nancy Pelosi, took a
trip to Taiwan - the first time a high level U.S.
official had traveled there in over 30 years.
SIERRA: China wasn’t too happy about it.
PBS NewsHour: As soon as Pelosi arrived,
China announced the beginning of air and sea
military exercises around the island.
PBS NewsHour: Ahead of the visit, China put its
military on high-alert, and flew fighter jets
close to Taiwan.
SIERRA:
I want to work through this situation and
look at it from every side. And I think it’s
only fair that we start with Taiwan itself,
the little guy caught between giants. So,
what do Taiwanese people want?
LIN: So the National Chengchi University,
which is one of the top universities in Taiwan,
has an election study center that, since 1992, has
conducted biannual polls. One is a poll about what
should Taiwan do about its cross-strait policy,
about its relationship with Beijing? And it asks
questions, should we just maintain the status quo
indefinitely, or should we maintain the status quo
and then decide at a later date to maybe change
it? Should we seek to unify with China, or should
we seek independence? And independence in this
context means something more like changing the
constitution, so that we're no longer officially
the Republic of China, and maybe changing the name
in something like the Republic of Taiwan, which
Beijing has said is a red line. The polls show
overwhelmingly that Taiwanese prefer the status
quo. So if you add together all the status quo
answers it's around like 88 percent of Taiwanese
people want to maintain the status quo. And so
I would say that Taiwanese people recognize that
there is a significant threat to their existence,
and you see it play out in the polls. And there
have been other polls too that have asked kind
of hypothetical questions like, if Beijing
didn't threaten us, what would be your preferred
kind of outcome? And you can see that it changes
dramatically where many Taiwanese people actually
prefer some sort of independence or some sort of
greater assertion of its sovereignty. And so this
kind of tells us that there's an understanding
about - pragmatism about that threat. The other
poll is a question about Taiwanese identity. So
in 1992, when the polls first began, there was a
large number of people who identified as Chinese
and only as Chinese, I think around 30 percent,
and the majority of people identified as both
Chinese and Taiwanese. Today, in 2023, 60 percent
of people in Taiwan identify as Taiwanese and
only as Taiwanese, whereas only about 3 percent
identify as Chinese and only as Chinese. And so
this is a dramatic shift in the past thirty years,
where Chinese identity has really dropped off,
and Taiwanese identity - solely being
Taiwanese - has become the majority.
SIERRA: Given the danger and tensions of
the moment, it’s perhaps no surprise that
a majority of Taiwanese would prefer the status
quo to gambling their freedom in a conflict. But
it’s also telling that when asked what they
would choose if there was no danger, most say
they would prefer some form of independence.
SIERRA: Watching all of this is the United States.
Yes, Beijing will decide whether or not to invade
Taiwan. But the U.S. must decide whether or not to
defend Taiwan if it happens.
SIERRA:
So, let's talk about the United States.
Over the last year, there's been more and
more news suggesting that the U.S. is
perhaps on a path to war over Taiwan.
So I just want to get this straight. The U.S.
doesn't recognize Taiwan as a country. Taiwan
is very far from the U.S. mainland. So why on
Earth would the U.S. risk a war over Taiwan
with its most powerful adversary, China?
SACKS: Yeah, it's a very important question,
and I think it's something that we should
discuss and have a robust debate about in
the United States. So I'll just outline what
I see as some of the U.S. interests at stake
in the Taiwan Strait. Number one, pull out a
map. Look at where Taiwan is located. It is
located at a critical point in the first island
chain, which stretches from Japan down through
Taiwan and into the Philippines. Japan and the
Philippines, of course, two very important U.S.
allies. And with the integrity of the first
island chain the way it is right now, it is
very difficult for China to project military power
far beyond its shores to threaten U.S. allies or
even the United States itself. But if it annexes
Taiwan and stations its military on the island,
then that all changes. China would be less than
one hundred miles away from Japan. It would be far
closer to the Philippines. It would make a U.S.
defense of those allies incredibly difficult.
SIERRA: For years now, China has been
expanding its military presence in the Pacific,
building installations in disputed areas,
and generally bullying smaller neighbors
over territory in the South China Sea. This
has led some strategists to fear that the U.S.
could eventually lose its ability to project
power into the Pacific, something the country
has been able to do since World War II.
SACKS: You have to reckon, I think, with what
happens in the strategic thinking and the calculus
of U.S. allies the day after a Chinese takeover of
Taiwan. In my view, Japanese leaders view this
as a critical interest for Japanese security,
and if China takes over Taiwan, Japan has grave
doubts as to whether the United States can or
would come to its defense. And a more powerful
country like Japan, it either seeks to accommodate
China's interests and moves closer to China,
but it could also pursue some form of strategic
autonomy, which would likely involve developing
nuclear weapons of its own and a major increase
in defense capabilities and spending. Relatively
weaker countries like the Philippines, to me,
I just think that they essentially decide
to accommodate China's interests and live
with the fact that China is the new dominant
power in the Indo-Pacific, and the era of U.S.
influence is kind of over. And so I think
this has major implications for U.S. allies
and partnerships in the region, which is our most
important asymmetrical advantage over China when
we're thinking of how we compete with China in
the long-term competition. I think you look at it
economically - what is our interest in deterring a
conflict in the Taiwan Strait? Over 90 percent of
the world's most advanced semiconductors are made
in Taiwan. Around 70 percent of all semiconductors
in the world are manufactured in Taiwan. So
regardless of whether the United States chooses to
intervene on Taiwan's behalf, if deterrence fails
and China uses force, we're going to see a global
economic depression with trillions of dollars
shaved off global GDP that will be incredibly
difficult to recover from, given the nature
of the semiconductor industry, how difficult
it is to build those facilities elsewhere and
get up to speed. So that really emphasizes the
importance of deterrence, in my view.
SIERRA: We actually did a whole episode on
semiconductors and how important they are
to the U.S. In it, we take a really deep
dive into how the whole world relies
on Taiwan every day to keep the tech
economy running. You should check it out.
SIERRA: Bottom line, all of these factors together
make it a very real possibility that the U.S.
could choose to intervene if China invades.
SIERRA: So a bit of a logistics question. Let's
say that the U.S. commits to defending Taiwan from
an invasion. How would we even do that? Because
China is what, a hundred miles from Taiwan,
whereas we are thousands of miles away.
SACKS: Yeah. So geography I think does cut in
China's favor, but we shouldn't oversimplify
this and say, "Well, this would just be a walk
in the park for the People's Liberation Army."
We're still talking about a need to cross ninety
miles of treacherous waters, where they would
be targeted by Taiwanese missiles and ships
and potentially U.S. submarines, again, missiles
and ships as well. And so it would be incredibly
difficult for China to pull that off, and China
has to also anticipate that even if it lands on
Taiwan and successfully builds a beachhead that
it would face urban warfare and significant
resistance from the Taiwanese people. So I don't
think that the Chinese leadership underestimates
the difficulty of pulling this off. Now,
from the U.S. perspective, I think that
a critical thing that we have to think about is
Japan's role in a conflict. Yes, we're far away,
but the United States does have over fifty
thousand troops in Japan, as well as advanced
capabilities that would be relevant for a conflict
over Taiwan. And so this is a big question mark,
though. To what extent is Japan involved in a
Taiwan contingency? To what extent does it support
U.S. operations, assist in U.S. operations?
But if there is full Japanese support and if
we do more to build our ability to work with our
Japanese allies and to really operate together,
then we still have enduring strengths over the
PLA that we can bring to bear in the Taiwan
Strait. And we should also note that, yes, China
has overseen a remarkable modernization of the
People's Liberation Army, and on paper, the PLA is
very strong, but these officers, most of them have
never seen combat. The last time China fought a
war was in 1979 with Vietnam, and the last time
that it fought a really large-scale war was the
Korean War in 1950. So the United States, yes,
we have big gaps, and we need to address those.
The war in Ukraine has shown that our defense
industrial base is not where it needs to be, for
instance, and we need to take steps to address
those shortfalls. But I don't think that we should
assess this - the ‘if China decides to go for it,
it can achieve a fait accompli,’ and basically,
we should just throw up our hands and say,
"You've succeeded."
SIERRA: What would a
conflict over Taiwan do to the world?
LIN: It depends on the kind of conflict. Kind
of a worst case scenario is a full on amphibious
invasion and occupation of Taiwan by the PLA,
the Chinese military. And that would be, in my
opinion, would be completely disastrous. I think
it would draw in other powers into a conflict. I
think the United States, even if it doesn't really
respond by deploying the military to defend
Taiwan, I think that it would involve lots of
punitive measures, economic punitive measures
that we're seeing towards Russia currently.
But it would be much more drastic because Russia
is an important energy supplier, but its economy
is not as integrated into the global economy,
whereas China is the so-called ‘factory of the
world.’ And any kind of military action would
take offline, not just Taiwan's manufacturing,
but also I think would have an effect on China's
inclusion in the global economy. And that
would just grind things to a total halt.
SIERRA: What is the risk of escalation here? What
about the possibility of nuclear escalation?
SACKS: So I think that's a really important
question, and I think frankly, that's one
that we haven't really contended with enough,
because it's so difficult to wrap our
heads around it. What we do know, though,
is that China is making remarkable advances in
its nuclear arsenal, that it is now in the midst
of a huge buildup in its nuclear arsenal. And,
in my view, it has direct relevance to Taiwan.
So I don't have a good answer. Nobody knows
whether a conflict over Taiwan could be kept
to conventional weaponry, but I also think
nobody knows for sure that a conflict over
Taiwan would immediately go nuclear. Again,
we can make well-educated guesses about how a
conflict would play out, but I think anybody who
tells you that they know for certain one way or
the other is not being truthful.
SIERRA: So it seems pretty clear that
this is something every person on Earth
really has an interest in preventing.
So what can be done to avoid the conflict?
SACKS: At a fundamental level, I think, that the
political foundation or framework should remain in
place, which is that the United States maintains
its One China policy, does not recognize Taiwan
as an independent country. Taiwan acts responsibly
and doesn't seek to declare independence
for itself. And within that context, though,
I think we need to do a lot more to bolster
deterrence in the Taiwan Strait. That's things
like for the United States to prioritize things
like stealth bombers, submarines, long range
missiles that would all be incredibly important in
a conflict over Taiwan, to assist Taiwan in also
overhauling its military, doing a lot more to help
train Taiwan's military to prepare for a conflict,
and also thinking through things with Taiwan
in terms of civil resilience and its ability
to hold out during a conflict. Taiwan imports
nearly all of its energy. It is a net importer
of food and medical supplies. So, how can we
help Taiwan shore up those vulnerabilities to
ensure that it can hold out long enough to enable
the United States to assist Taiwan in the face of
Chinese aggression? I do think that we want to do
what we can to minimize the urgency that the PRC
feels with respect to Taiwan. So I don't think we
want to feed fears that this is slipping away and
that time is not on its side. My own view is that
there's only so much we can do in that regard, but
we shouldn't play into those fears. And I think
that with Taiwan, there's a whole bucket of what
we do with Taiwan, and we need to do a lot more
to ensure its economic competitiveness as well.
I think we should negotiate a bilateral trade
agreement with Taiwan. We should work with Taiwan
on global supply chain issues. We should help
ensure that the PRC is not able to economically
marginalize Taiwan. But there's a whole bucket,
also, of things that we don't do with Taiwan
that, in this scenario, are just as important. So
in my view, we should do less that is heavy on the
symbolism side, which does play into this Chinese
fear and is likely to provoke a PRC response
without actually meaningfully improving Taiwan's
defensive capabilities or its resilience, but we
should do a lot more on the substantive side.
SIERRA: You know, in certain circles, it can feel
like people think conflict between the
United States and China is inevitable,
and that this could be sort of a self-fulfilling
prophecy, the logic that sooner or later China
will move to take Taiwan back, the U.S. will be
compelled to intervene, and obviously we all, the
Taiwanese people especially, have an interest in
preventing this. So how do you sort of avoid that
mindset? How do we remain open to off-ramps?
LIN: Yeah, I think that's really important because
I think there are elements of, especially
at the U.S. foreign policy circles,
that there are some who think that conflict is
inevitable. And I don't think that's the case. I
think that we have to keep in mind that war would
be tremendously costly for all parties involved,
and we have to assume that there's still some
rationality involved in foreign policy making
for Beijing, that they're not going to
act as recklessly as some might assume,
that even though there is maybe a window of
military advantage, that doesn't necessarily
mean that they will make a political decision
to use the military for a political action. And
I would just make sure that everybody is reminded
of that part. There are lots of risks involved and
there are lots of costs, and I think that there
are ways that we should keep off-ramps open,
as you've said, don't make any reckless
unilateral actions, and then hope that all
parties involved also see that the best
way to pursue a future is to maintain
the status quo and not rock the boat.
SACKS: Our aim shouldn't be to solve the Taiwan
issue, but instead to continue to finesse this in
such a way where China doesn't feel compelled to
attack Taiwan, and Taiwan can feel confident
in its ability to maintain its democratic
institutions and its economic vitality. The
overriding goal of U.S. policy, in my view,
is to ensure that this remains difficult enough
for Chinese leadership that when Xi Jinping
wakes up in the morning and he looks across the
Taiwan Strait, he says, today is not the day,
that he has real doubts in his mind as to whether
the Chinese military can accomplish the objective
he sets out.
SIERRA:
Hey everyone! So this is actually the last
episode of our seventh season. Time truly
does fly. We will be working behind the scenes on
a whole new batch of episodes, so if you have any
topics you would like to hear more about write
us and let us know at whyitmatters@cfr.org! We
will be back in the fall with fresh content.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode and
more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes. If you ever
have any questions or suggestions or just want
to chat with us, email whyitmatters@cfr.org or
hit us up on Twitter at @CFR_org.
SIERRA: Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The
opinions expressed on the show are solely
that of the guests, not of CFR, which takes no
institutional positions on matters of policy.
SIERRA: The show is produced by Asher Ross
and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer
is Markus Zakaria. Our associate podcast
producer is Molly McAnany. Our interns this
summer are Bella Quercia and Jiwon Lim.
SIERRA: Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Noah Berman, Ester Fang, and Mariel Ferragamo. Our
theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
SIERRA: You can subscribe to the
show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
YouTube or wherever you get your audio.
SIERRA: For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you in the fall!